to anyone who doesn't know you who's
watching this do you want to maybe just
give a brief little uh explanation oh my
God that's the background
um
how do you summarize yourself uh I
played a lot of fortnite I make YouTube
videos some people like them some people
don't get a lot of hate comments well
that's because you also get a ridiculous
amount of views on your videos so it's
sometimes sometimes but um yeah
only five million views I fell off ah I
do say that oh my god oh bro I wish man
I wish yeah you know one day one day
maybe take Fortnight is a different
breed
um yeah no I've been doing it eight
years eight and a half years uh started
smashing things with machines that was
my first channel wait what and then uh
there's a long story
oh [__] wow
I was bored and I didn't want to do I
didn't want to be a concrete forever so
my [__] I'll make videos because I
watch a lot of Machinima yeah
at this point oh when I when I first I
was 19 I think yeah
yeah 19. um sort of just realized didn't
want to do construction forever yeah
yeah I was like oh well there's enough
Gamers out there there's enough people
doing that [__] so I'll do something
different so I just was trying to think
what do I have that other people
wouldn't have right and access to likely
I know how to drive an excavator I know
how to drive a Bobcat so after work I
just like set up a microwave like swing
around like I'm playing t-ball with an
excavator I was like a budget slo-mo
guys
well no I bought a slow-mo camera it was
like a really [__] one so I was like and
this was like yeah like almost 10 years
ago nine years ago
he's like 360 p and she was really bad
it's kind of funny
um after six months of doing that I had
60 subs and then all my camera gear got
stolen oh oh [__] it was in a regional
Country Town lots of crime
um and that's where I was like [__] it
might as well do gaming all I had left
was my laptop it came full circle you're
like [__] this game as well it's more
like I have no choice now I can't
replace this like five grand the camera
gear that was my wife saying
did you like they broke in and uh yeah
it's still unsolved mystery so if anyone
knows anyone has any tip-offs look how
you sound you sounded so like you're
like they can just take things no no I
mean I mean I'm just like I mean I'm
just like how did it like that's a lot
of equipment you can't just like it's
not like you can just pickpocket that
you know uh well yeah it was just
overnight they just break in take it it
was wasn't the nicest area that I was
operating in right but um
look cops just don't really give a [__]
they're like that's five grand stuff
like hopefully your insurance will cover
in two years wait did they take anything
else aside from the camera uh
I don't remember what they it was just
like a lot of camera gear that's all it
really was bro this is like a [__]
hit job I think it was quite literally
like it was in a box like sitting like
right there yeah so as soon as soon as
they get in it's like right there it's
like [__] easy
um let's look for easy targets but um
yeah enough I had no choice to do gaming
that point yeah I was like yeah
like what if if all of my gear got
stolen I don't think I'd want to make
videos anymore oh I cried I would be
honest I was growing man I was crying it
was like a buff treaty at that point but
I was tears Mars I thought my dream was
dead I was like that's this was all my
savings was on this like this was this
my dream was YouTube your full-time job
back then or no not at this point yeah
well that was like my savings I was like
bro I was still living with my parents
so I was like didn't have any costs so
it was either like
getting on the pier doing drugs or by
camera gear you know so yeah I was like
well I don't want to be a drop kick so
I'll do I'll Chase my dreams instead of
doing all my friends were doing was it
easy to kind of pick up gaming and and
making videos about that or was it about
I always loved gaming like I was a
massive nerd um
yeah yeah so I was already but I just
didn't think it was realistic because it
was you know even people to this day oh
it's too saturated you can't do it yeah
if you think it's realistic odds are
you're probably way too overconfident
yeah massively but um I started out
doing like American Sports like Madden
okay I had like a I was like the
Australian kid that loved American
Sports and that was another way to be
different I used to share it on Reddit
put my first videos on Reddit
um but Aussie reviews but well I kind of
just did really dumb [__] like everyone
was playing the game super seriously
they're like competitive they do these
series or whatever I was like okay take
the fattest dude in the game can you
score a touchdown
no I sit there for 12 hours trying to
score until like the game glitched in
some way so we could school and then I
put it on Reddit and everyone loved it
yeah
sitting there saying like oh [__] yeah
[__] [__] yeah because I was fresh off
the job site and then
yeah so like instantly as soon as I was
doing gaming within like three months I
had like 50k Subs it was like so I was
like oh [__] I should have done this
from stuff was that like variety at that
point or was it no it was just it was
just like American Sports like
basketball Madden I think it was a year
in I started doing like one of the games
and [__] well but I think you already
like pinpointed the niche of just like
you know not doing what everyone else
was exactly just being like that's where
it is also an Aussie playing American
sport how did you get into American
Sports I grew up playing baseball right
whatever reason uh in Australia yeah I
was I was [__] how
really enough where I grew up uh uh I've
never even seen this field in Australia
you'd be surprised like so Sydney does
decent um I was on the Central Coast so
like two hours north of Sydney whatever
reason my cousin was playing it
um he'd later go on to play in America
sorry my brother oh wow you know
reasonably good genetics in the family
but not for me not for me I was dog [__]
but it did mean my eyes were sort of
open to you know foreign sport right one
day I happened to see a Family Guy
episode oh yeah uh and had Tom Brady in
it uh which I don't know he's my guy
he's my guy okay
um and whatever reason I just remember
that so one day I was just any EB Games
yeah so mad and I was like oh [__] I'll
try it yeah bless
[__] yes
um but yeah I was just like yeah no one
else plays this game the way I would I
kind of took that energy and saw the
success from that like when I started
doing indie games and everything same
kind of thing when I started doing
fortnite same kind of thing I feel like
I saw it slightly differently right not
that I was revolutionary but I
definitely saw it slightly differently
it was a mini like when you're growing
up was it mainly just sports games you
were playing or just like a little bit
of everything oh bro I was a [__]
nerd
bro you're on a podcast fortnite yeah
my first two loves were RuneScape and
wow so that's my all right they took my
entire childhood years and I was bullied
relentlessly for it yeah I might never
leave the house uh I mean I look I did
the Call of Duties I did the fifas I did
all that yeah a lot of Age of Empires
like Total War series like all the
strategy nerdy [__] yeah but yeah I
don't even think that's that nerdy maybe
I'll just put it up in a place where I'm
just like
so I got so bullied with that [__] it
was nerdy that sounds cool to me man
yeah I think it's cool yeah yeah playing
RuneScape
I'm so I'm so sad I missed the whole
RuneScape kind of like area it's not too
late oh yeah yeah I did play it like
once for like a stream and then it was
it was a lot of fun although I would say
we played it with like a what is it like
not a multiplier but like it's an
accelerator right so we did like a
promotion with RuneScape and they had a
server that was like times 50 XP oh
that'd be nice I don't know it suddenly
came to the realization now I was like
I'm having a lot of fun but if I just
played this at normal speed how long
would it take to get through all the
content I took I did in that four hours
I mean after that I went and played on
the the time 50 server a little bit more
and I was grinding levels I was like oh
my God this is so slow yeah now as soon
as you go back to the normal game it's
awful but it's it's weird because it's
kind of game that you play where you do
another [__] yeah that's right everyone
who tells yeah who's played it does that
they're like I'm doing something else I
just keep clicking it while I'm doing
the other thing yeah it's such a weird
experience because you're playing it but
you hate playing it because it's such a
grind
but you just when you get like a level
or a 99 or a big difference
oh but I mean at least wow you're
playing the goddamn game I feel like
when you're you literally click and then
don't click for another like 30 seconds
you click the tree and then you're like
okay
you can try and come back like once
every 20 minutes yeah
like where's that a game at that point
but like I love it it kind of sounds
like a gotcha game to me yeah like it's
just taking like like it was one of the
OG like grind mechanics game yeah yeah
and then obviously gacha took took a lot
of inspiration from those type of games
like Cookie Clicker and all those games
yeah we don't [__] click anything you
know just let it sit yeah yeah you just
you just click every now and then and
then you're like all right I'm just
gonna leave it for 10 years I'm Gonna
Leave the [__] quick clicker on I
hate those games I I always just get
like I'd always start Cookie Clicker and
then I just hack it just do inspect
element and change it
yeah
he's changed one value like you beat the
game but you don't get the gratification
of the clicking yeah but that's actually
the point of beating Cookie Clicker
there is no point right now I don't
remember I don't think it doesn't it's
just like a it's like just to say
dopamine bandage yeah yeah I think
that's why like I found myself actually
kind of obsessing with it for like a
three hour period And so I'm like okay
I'm gonna hack and hack this and ruin it
for myself it's like when you cheat in a
game yeah if you're cheating a game it
ruins the game yeah always so like you
don't want to play it anymore it's like
a way to solve yourself from being
addicted like if you if you play WoW or
something you just buy not so much in
WoW but like
you buy all the gold you buy all the
gear yeah all after 10 minutes because
there's nothing to achieve right yeah so
like yes and then you move on you break
that addiction yeah it's all it's all
about the journey right if you don't put
effort in you don't feel like the
gratification of actually getting the
items and actually getting like the
power that you worked for which is like
kind of like I guess Why Pay to Win
games is a complete broke in the system
now you know yeah yeah so even in those
you can't even pay enough there's always
like they slowly like diminishing return
it to the point that you're dropping
thousands and you still can't quite
always win yeah yeah